auf die inhaltlichen überschneidungen
von grünen und linken wollen wir gerne
jetzt schauen zusammen mit gerd baum dem
letzten bundesinnenminister den die fdp
in einer regierung gestellt hat vor
knapp 40 jahren in der spd geführten
regierung von helmut schmidt 1978 bis 82
für muntari baum
guten morgen herr warum sie haben die
zusammenarbeit mit den grünen gestern
nacht bei meinem kollegen markus lanz im
zdf als projekt bezeichnet was ist für
sie ein projekt
ja also beide parteien sind nicht teil
der großen koalition gewesen sie stehen
also nicht für den status quo sondern
für etwas neues und sehr interessant ist
dass sie bei jung und erstwählern sehr
guten abgeschnitten haben sie haben
einen zukunfts auftrag das heißt also
sie müssen jetzt die linien bestimmen
über die einzelheiten wird man dann im
einzelnen auch streiten aber die linie
muss stimmen dass wir die zukunft
sichern in sachen umwelt europa an all
den themen die jetzt dringend behandelt
werden müssen es kommt noch etwas hinzu
was soll denn passieren wenn die beiden
jetzt scheitern dann ist ja im grunde
der welt alles in sich zusammen das
heißt sie sind auch in gewisser hinsicht
zu einem erfolg verurteilt und ich sehe
die chancen gar nicht so schlecht denn
es bewegt sich etwas in der gesellschaft
die neue parteien struktur wird sichtbar
es ist eine vielfalt die uns jetzt hier
begegnen in der gesellschaft sind riesen
probleme in der welt in europa in
deutschland alles ist ein 1 1 mutti
wallander motivation jetzt ein projekt
zu machen also nicht nur einzelne
forderungen abzuhaken sondern das in ein
gesamtkonzept zu gießen in eine
richtungsentscheidung für die zukunft
also ermahnt sie sagen sie sagen
wahrscheinlich von den großen linien
herr baum was sind denn diese großen
linien wo sie sagen da sind grün und fdp
auf einer linie und wo sagen sie nein da
ist man doch weit voneinander entfernt
da muss man sich erst auf eine linie
da muss da muss man sich auf eine linie
einigen zb in dem spannungsverhältnis
was macht der markt was macht der staat
ich sehe da keine
unüberwindbare hinderungsgründe es ist
ja jetzt das ziel beispielsweise die
umweltkatastrophe zu vermeiden da geht
es darum wie erreicht man das ziel am
besten und da meine ich musste sich
beide bewegen der markt schafft nicht
alles aber mit mit regeln wird man auch
nicht alles schafft man braucht die die
kräfte der wirtschaft die kräfte die
idee das einzelne individuum aufbringen
muss und um die zukunft mitzugestalten
also ich bin wirklich relativ
optimistisch sehr gut und sagt ja das
ist doch schon mal ein guter anfang wenn
ich da rein grätschen darf bleiben wir
doch mal ganz konkret also hast du die
fdp sagt ganz klar schuldenbremse bleibt
die grünen sagen ja auch wir wollen die
schuldengrenze nicht auf bremse nicht
aufweichen aber wir wollen deutlich mehr
investitionen als das vielleicht die fdp
will wie geht das zusammen
sinnvolle investition will jedoch nicht
wie wollen sie habe von der investition
in bildung in unserer infrastruktur wir
wollen sinnvolle investition die also
das land dauerhaft
in die zukunft bringen und da wird man
sich doch einigen wie sie waren bürger
schultern nicht warten dann bereit wenn
ich da kurz rein greifen darf wenn wir
ist es bei der krankenversicherung da
möchte die möchten die grünen gerne eine
bürgerversicherung also alle zahlen in
die gleiche krankenversicherung ein
während sie während die fdp ganz klar
sagt nein dieses system gesetzliche und
private krankenversicherungen das wollen
wir so beibehalten das ist ja ein
diametralen gegensatz ja
ja das wird schwierig und da wird man
genau rechnen müssen und man wird auch
prinzipien zur disposition stellen wir
haben eine andere annäherung an die an
die lösung als die grünen und dass das
sind ich will gar nicht verschweigen es
gibt auch schwierige probleme aber ich
glaube die tatsache dass man sich jetzt
von eingefahrenen gleisen weg bewegen
musste etwas gemeinsam zu etwas neuem
dieser druck ist da und wenn die
parteien das bestehen sozusagen die
beiden kleineren als klaus der neuen
koalition dann wird ihnen das beiden
helfen und idee und weiter voranbringen
ich bin fest überzeugt
dieser druck der jetzt auch der
zeitliche druck der besteht wird zur
lösung führen ich meine den druck gab es
vorher vier jahren ja auch damals hat
man sich dann trotzdem nicht da
eigentlich beziehungsweise christian
lindner hat trotzdem zurückgezogen was
er sagt denn uns allen wer sagt denn uns
allen jetzt dass christian lindner nicht
dass dieses jahr wieder so macht
das scheitern von jamaika ist ein trauma
und es bestimmt auch jetzt den gang der
dinge man will auf keinen fall sich so
verhält wie das 2017 geschehen ist das
ist auch ein gutes vorzeichen man will
die fehler vermeiden nicht wollen dass
das gilt auch für die für die spd man
wird jetzt genau ich aufpassen müssen
was passiert eigentlich in den
fraktionen nicht wahr die vielen neuen
mitglieder bei der wahl der spd
beispielsweise sind die einen
unsicherheitsfaktor was passiert bei den
grünen legen die fdp ist ziemlich stabil
also geben wir jetzt mal davon aus das
ist ein bekanntes scholz gibt aber das
ist ja auch noch nicht aus gehören herr
baumann sie haben ja einst den
linksliberalen freiburger kreis
innerhalb der fdp gegründet ich gehe
also wahrscheinlich recht in der annahme
dass sie wahrscheinlich doch die ampel
er präferiere noever jamaika ist es aus
ihrer sicht so dass wenn es hier nicht
zu einer ampel kommt und zu einer
einigung dann steht für sie auch
christian lindner als parteichef infrage
das steht überhaupt nicht zur debatte
als mann der da wird sich wie die
anderen bemühen jetzt zu einer einigung
zu kommen ich mache keinen hehl aus
meiner meinung ich war immer ein
anhänger des sozialen liberalismus wie
dem in dem freibad legendären freiburger
programm vor 50 jahren das zum ausdruck
gekommen ist also mit mit auch mit
kritik überhaupt an auswüchsen des
kapitalismus und wir waren die erste
umweltpartei ich war ja auch
umweltminister das kann und muss man
meines erachtens wiederbeleben das wird
der fdp gut tun inwiefern gut tun
weil sie weil sie ihr jetzt sichtbar
ihre thematische spektrum wieder
arbeiter das hat sie schon längst getan
in der fraktion gibt es kräftige jüngere
kräfte
fachleute menschen die sich engagieren
auf dem feld der umweltpolitik der
bürgerrechte und so weiter die jetzt die
jetzt ja auch sichtbarer werden die fdp
hat die zeit genutzt der opposition und
es ist eine eine eine führungsriege
nachgewachsen die jetzt auch sichtbarer
werden wird und sichtbarer werden muss
gerhart baum wenn ich das liebevoll
sagen darf ein urgestein der fdp vielen
danke ihnen herr baum hier im phoenix
tagesgespräch
ja ja noch schönen tag in auch der baum